why don't we go next to Nick from Harlem
Nick welcome to the program what can I
do for you today
hey there can you hear me okay yes I can
okay well first time long time thank you
so much for your work um I actually have
a question about uh the Pac-Man Finance
Channel sure
uh so I know you have a background in uh
like you have educational background in
finance and I don't know if you've ever
taught or if you teach courses but for
me the Pacman Financial has been like an
educational experience as I'm sure is
one of your intentions yes I've even had
the opportunity to like share it with
um some of my conservative conservative
um I guess I would say acquaintances and
you know they end up also tuning in to
other you know the other Pac-Man Channel
your main Channel and that you know it's
kind of I found that kind of be to be
interesting and my question is I guess
um would you ever consider doing a
call-in aspect for Pac-Man Finance like
not necessarily a financial advice
um but just you know how to or you know
if folks kind of have you know specific
questions about their specific
situations I I don't know what what are
your thoughts around that it is
something I would consider the thing
you've got to be really careful about is
you don't want to end up giving fine
Financial advice in a context where then
it blows up on you you know in some way
yeah um but it would be at least
conceivably super interesting
yeah yeah thank you and then I have one
other quick question for you sure please
all right so um here you know in New
York we have um uh an oversight agency
of the police department called the
Civilian Complaint review board and um
they're considered to be one of the I
guess what you would say Premier
agencies in the country when it comes to
oversight of police misconduct
um and so but what I'm seeing a lot is
uh folks uh criticizing them for being
ineffective and they're there's
legislation actually in the state that's
um trying to remove the agency and
replace it with something else and so my
question is not specifically about the
agency but it's about the idea and I
think I've heard you say this once
before about
um if we are going to we can criticize
for example Biden for policies and stuff
like that but um if we don't have
something to replace it with what or
what what are we to do you know and it's
like I it just frustrates me a lot of
the time that um people want to
criticize like certain you know
philosophies or certain things that are
existing not even a philosophy like
things are in place but how are you
going to replace what you're criticizing
and what is you know and how do you
suppose people can deal with that or as
a movement of progressives even you know
well you're getting at something that is
um you know it's one of these truisms
where it's very it's much easier to
criticize than it is to come up with
solutions to problems and that doesn't
necessarily mean that just because
you've identified a problem but you
don't have a solution you should be
ignored I mean it's it's not that real
like let me give you an example this is
it's it's sort of um it's it's kind of
silly but it also makes sense you could
be watching a car race a NASCAR race and
know nothing about NASCAR vehicles but
identify a car that has something wrong
with it it's it's like wobbling down the
track and it's slower than all the
others and there's blue smoke coming out
of it even without knowing much about
how to fix that problem you could
identify that something is wrong so I
don't want to laugh off the fact
that it's totally legit to say hey you
know what
the status quo with student lending
isn't working you've got all these
people they take out these student loans
college is outrageously expensive they
graduate they have a crazy debt but the
job they get doesn't pay much money that
it's great that we can identify that you
don't necessarily need to know whether
the solution comes from regulation or a
higher minimum wage or making it harder
to borrow or putting price caps on
colleges or creating a job market that's
more uh robust for non-college job you
don't have to know the answer to be able
to identify a problem so I I don't think
that it's useful to just say hey just
pointing out problems doesn't really
have value however if you're in a
position of power as an elected official
or you're arguing that you should be
voted into a position of power you damn
well better have some suggestions as to
how to fix the problem
that makes absolute uh sense to me thank
you for that input uh yeah thank you I
appreciate that that makes a lot of
sense all right Nick from Harlem thanks
for the call
thank you all right there he goes now on
to all sorts of other things Nick from
Harlem let's go to Chris from Georgia
Chris from Georgia welcome to the
program
um I'll let you get settled here and
unmute yourself what's on your mind
today
Chris from Georgia you're on I can't
hear you though probably you have your
wrong audio device selected
Chris from Georgia welcome to the show
all right and there goes
Chris from Georgia that's sad I'm sad we
weren't able to make the connection
let's go to Tai from Iowa Ty from Iowa
welcome what's going on hello David can
you hear me yes I can
okay
um so I wanted to ask this I just
thought this was kind of weird so
I noticed you know how like a lot of
Republicans will say like well the
Democrats are just Communists and
socialists and all this stuff right yeah
so I think it's kind of weird like I
remember Trump put out that one thing
and he said like China would have never
flew a spy balloon over me because China
respects me too much yeah I just thought
that was really kind of weird to hear
well it's absurd I mean we we have we
since found out that China did fly spy
balloons during Trump's term uh Trump
apparently Trump apparently wasn't told
about it which fine but the idea that
they respect him too much or fear him
too much and this actually gets to a
broader issue of of the idea of fear as
the way to get power and uh respect in
politics you know fear and this came up
during my interview on the Patrick Bet
David podcast where he said is it bad
that nobody fears the U.S anymore and I
was like well what evidence do you have
of that he was like forget it you know
like we got off onto a different thing
but fear will make your
uh adversaries and allies
involve you only enough to minimize the
threat from you but not enough to make
you a serious participant and so like
the fear example let's let's Grant maybe
other countries were afraid of trump
they were afraid because he was so
unstable and that only gets them to deal
with Trump in a way that will be the
minimum to prevent him from doing
something completely insane but he'll
never be taken seriously when fear is
the main thing that goes on and so
that's why I think that this idea of
fear to gain power is fundamentally
flawed
yeah it just was kind of weird to hear
because it's kind of like he
it seems like he'll praise China when
need be but then he'll also say that the
Democrats are communist but then it's
like well you're you're praising this
thing that to you is like a far left
dictatorship it doesn't really make a
lot of sense you know right absolutely
um yeah I think uh so so that's my view
on that I hope I've answered your
question
yeah that makes sense all right Ty from
Iowa thank you for the call
all right thank you all right there he
goes some pretty solid calls today I
must say